all right here with reaction former
senior counselor to president trump
kellyanne conway along with former
arkansas governor mike huckabee you know
kelly and i'll start with you tonight
because you're a pollster and you're
great at your job and you we've known
each other for 27 years for crying out
loud and you look at every single poll
the lowest approval rating depending on
which poll it is that they've ever had
you know culminating with the 33
approval rating with quinnipiac and
is there anything that they could do
within the range that that they have and
that is
keeping
their climate alarmist religious cult
happy because i don't see anything that
they can do on the economy or on the
borders that will satisfy the base of
this new democratic party which means
he's in a box
he's got to just hope and pray that
things get better and that's not usually
how it works
it doesn't work that way sean people
won't vote for you if they feel like
you're not listening to them and not
connecting with them and he's clearly
not he's down in the polls among
suburban women key to his victory in
2020 among independents key to his
victory and young people
who overwhelmingly voted for him in 2020
they've all just cratered in their
approval of his performance in the job
and on key issues and he's got another
problem now you just alluded to it with
peter ducey he's got a problem inside
the senate democratic base so gary
peters who represents the state of
michigan that is that is near the
canadian border not the mexican border
he's against every moving title 42
because he heads up the democratic
senate committee and he's looking at the
electoral map this year and he sees
trouble in places where joe biden's
approval rating is in the low to mid 30s
georgia
nevada arizona pennsylvania north
carolina do you see a trend here and so
he's got joe biden's got nobody half
happy i think the only thing declining
more than joe biden's approval ratings
is joe biden and people now see that
they're talking about 2024 i find that
to be very arrogant at best
ukrainians are suffering americans are
suffering under the yoke of inflation
and border insecurity crime is rising in
our cities
kids are still trying to catch up from
that loss learning we have real problems
and pain here and he's talking about his
2024 political prospects but i have
never seen a president and a vice
president's numbers fall so
precipitously and them not wanting to
listen and learn obama and bill clinton
the only president clinton will ever
have
they both suffered grievous losses in
their first midterm elections and
snapped back around moderated a little
bit and won re-election joe biden shows
no signs of his willingness or his
ability to do that you know
you're right on target which leads me to
governor huckabee from arkansas
you could say a lot of things about bill
clinton but he was a great politician
and after that midterm election
and he got walloped
he came back with the era of big
government is over the end of welfare as
we know it uh prior to that or after at
some point there was a sister soldier
moment that that went viral so he showed
an ability to read the public
lack of satisfaction with his with his
job and he turned he changed he shifted
he adjusted i don't see that biden has
the capability to do it i don't think
his base would tolerate it
sean there's no education in the second
kick of a mule
and there's a problem that joe biden has
that bill clinton didn't
clinton might get kicked once by the
mule but he never let it happen again
joe biden stands there and gets kicked
over and over and doesn't realize he's
been kicked in the head by the mule and
that's his problem uh you were talking a
moment ago and i burst out laughing i'm
glad i was on the air and the mic wasn't
hot because it might have been a little
bit troubling but
when you were saying you invite jen saki
to come on and spend an hour
i thought yeah there's a greater
likelihood that i'm going to ride a
unicorn in the leprechaun rodeo to win
the pot of gold at the end of the
rainbow well wait a minute
i believe in miracles that could happen
you never know
well that would be one that would be
a biblical proportion if it ever should
happen but this is an administration
that does not want to answer the
questions because they don't have an
answer for those questions and joe biden
can say that he wants to run again let's
hope he does nothing would be better
to forever ensconce republicans in power
and i think republicans need to be very
careful that we don't rest
too easily on his failures but that we
show the american people that there's
really some policies we'd like to
implement we'd like to cut their taxes
we'd like to secure their border we'd
like to bring america back to the world
with a level of respect we truly like to
see the oil and gas that's under our own
feet supply our energy in an affordable
way rather than paying putin and the
saudis
a ransom in order to have enough to heat
our homes and cool our homes in the
summer we've got a real message out
there it's time to use it you know newt
gingrich was on my radio show uh today
kellyanne and we both agree it's kind of
time for republicans not to take it for
granted not to run on joe's a failure
although that's pretty transparent and
obvious but to lay out the ideas and
promises and put it down on paper that
if you elect us we will do these very
specific things
i like the idea because then we get to
hold them accountable for what they
promise they'll do do you like that idea
i love it and it's reminiscent of the
1994 contract with america and newt
gingrich's great success and you know
sean that contract with america was
signed on september 27th 1994 on the
capital steps right behind in the image
that was five weeks before election day
this is all coming together so much more
quickly but you're right people vote
according to affirmative policies
forward-looking
principles and that's important and just
one last thing joe biden seems unable to
do what the last many presidents right
left and center were able to do which is
be led by the people once in a while
presidents both have to lead the people
and be led by the people in this way
people are so excited to not have to
wear a mask on airplanes and on amtrak
and instead of him instead of him
standing up and saying this happened on
my watch on donald trump's watch you had
to wear a mask you had to stay
home for 45 days
instead they're thinking of suing the
cdc or suing and saying let's take this
all the way to supreme court this makes
no sense once in a while claim and
victory go where the people are they
don't have they don't seem to have a
sense of people and i think his 50 years
in washington turns out to be a
tremendous liability not an asset
governor i want to give you the same
question would would republicans making
promises on paper hold them more
accountable and
they have to have their words and
promises
match their rhetoric their actions match
their rhetoric
absolutely and i think it's an important
thing republicans ought to be willing to
be held accountable every person who's
elected i don't care what party they're
with they ought to be accountable for
the things that they said they were
going to do and if they do it they
deserve to be reelected if they don't
they need to get the boot i think the
unicorn is definitely in the equation
down the road uh governor great to see
you kellyanne great to see you hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else